Okay.
Big Breaking news from the second democratic
debate that was held in the middle of last
week and the big breaking news is basically
the debate has had no impact whatsoever on
polling.
Okay.
Barely anything has moved.
We now have to post debate polls and I'll
show you the data in a second.
Just as a reminder, my analysis of the second
democratic debate was that in night one it
was the Bernie Warren progressive duo that
really won the night.
Either of them could be said too, to have
one.
I think they both did well.
Some people in my saying, it was Bernie who
did better than Warren, so I'm saying the
opposite.
It was Warren who did better than Bernie.
Otherwise the performances were so poor that
I actually had Maryanne Williamson in third
place in night.
One of the debate night too.
I believe Andrew Yang stood out and then I
believe that actually Joe Biden did well,
not because he said anything particularly
great, but because he just weathered constant
attacks from all of the other candidates,
other candidates coming in or most of them
anyway, a clearly with the agenda of going
after Biden, it made Biden particularly as
some of those attacks fell flat.
It made Biden's sort of seem like the calm
rational guy.
His politics are to my right.
I disagree with him on much policy, but I
did think that he came away solid in that
debate.
We now have polling from uh, after this second
debate and we will put up on the screen for
you the polling before debate one, the polling
before debate too, and now the post debate
too polling, which are a numbers based on
two post debate polls, one from Harvard Harris,
one from politico morning consult averaged
and what you will notice the changes are Biden
up slightly, Bernie up the most, Warren down.
Interestingly, Camilla Harris slightly down.
Everybody else basically unchanged the Zeros
and ones still at zero and one no real movement
for Andrew Yang.
Technically actually down a bit, all still
within the margin of error.
Uh, so continuing to see absolutely no real
effect for the zeroes and ones from participating
in these debates.
Uh, many of them are not going to make it
to the third debate on September 12th.
And My expectation is that at least some of
them are going to end their campaigns once
they can't participate in the debates.
It is difficult to really justify continuing
in the race unless they think, well, I could
keep raising money one way or the other.
So what's important to understand now is that
historically at this point, most often the
leaders in primary polling become the nominees,
but not always.
Okay.
Could change this year.
But historically, recently, that's the way
it's been.
Let's take a look at that.
You will remember that.
So what we're looking at a, this is a November
20, 20 election and we're an August of 2019.
So we want to look at the equivalent time,
uh, about 13, 14 months before prior elections
in 2016, Donald Trump was leading the republican
primary, uh, in, uh, August of 2015.
And he ultimately was the nominee.
Um, Hillary Clinton was leading the Democratic
primary in August of 2015 and she ultimately
became the nominee in 2012.
Mitt Romney was ahead at this point in that
Republican primary.
He ultimately was also the nominee.
Now, some counterpoints are that in 2008,
uh, you had Hillary Clinton winning primary
polling at this point in the primary, and
she ultimately lost, of course, to Barack
Obama.
And Rudy Giuliani was also leading the Republican
primary in 2008 and ultimately lost to John
McCain.
So I'm not necessarily the bearer of good
or bad news here.
What I'm communicating is that recently, typically
the leaders in the primary polling right now
end up being the nominees.
But we have some examples from the last, uh,
okay.
I mean, it was 11 years ago, but still 12
years ago at this point.
Sometimes they don't.
What I think is abundantly clear is that there
is not a path that I see for anyone other
than Biden, Bernie Warren, maybe Harris, possibly
Pete, Buddha judge if he can turn it around.
But I don't think anyone below Buddha judge
right now has any shot at being the nominee.
If you disagree with me, if you see a way
that someone below the booted judge level
right now could become the Democratic nominee,
um, I want to hear from you and don't just
say, well, the polling could turn around and
they could take the lead because historically
that doesn't happen with people polling, you
know, under 5% at this point in time.
But tell me exactly what it is that's going
to happen, particularly if they don't even
make it to the debates that are in just five
weeks.
I want to hear from you.
Uh, let me know maybe via Twitter.
At d Pacman